Ресурси Землі невпинно зменшуються.
Апетит людства на корисні копалини настільки великий, що
природа вже не встигає відновлювати свої ресурси.
При цьому найбільших втрат довкіллю завдають міста.
Саме вони спричиняють 70% глобальних викидів вуглекислого газу.
Нідерландська столиця Амстердам хоче стати піонером екологічно чистого господарювання
і створити до 2050 року економіку замкненого циклу. В ідеалі абсолютно все
має використовуватися повторно заради захисту природи і клімату.
Сміттєзбиральні підприємства вилучають із поверхні
міських каналів Амстердама – "грахтів" - 42 тонни пластикових відходів на рік.
Це лише дещиця того, що плаває у річках.
Нам відомо, що близько двох третин пластику потрапляє у моря через річки.
А у річках, своєю чергою, опиняється багато сміття з вулиць.
У такий спосіб довкілля забруднюється пластиком.
Ми б хотіли перервати цей ланцюг вже на самому початку.
А допомагають у цьому бульбашки. Кілька років тому Анне Маріке Ефеленс
заснувала стартап під назвою "Великий бульбашковий бар'єр". Технологія працює так:
спеціальна трубка на дні водойми випускає бульбашки на поверхню.
Вони утворюють такий собі бар'єр, який затримує пластикові предмети,
а потім спрямовує їх за течією у контейнер-прийомник - навіть найдрібніші частинки.
Випробування показали, що у цей спосібможна виловити понад 80% плавучого сміття.
Міська очисна служба тричі на тиждень спорожнює контейнери.
Сьогодні пластику спіймалося у бульбашкову пастку небагато, адже не було вітру.
Поки "бульбашковий бар'єр" є лише в Амстердамі.
Однак невдовзі технологію, можливо, запозичать в усьому світі, зокрема і в Україні.
Наша технологія зацікавила багато галузей.
Уявіть собі підприємства, які заробляють на туризмі.
Їм же, звісно, хочеться мати чисті пляжі, річки та місця дозвілля.
Наша система дозволила б тримати все у чистоті, аби люди охоче туди приїздили.
"Бульбашковий бар'єр" фінансується урядом Нідерландів.
Нині стартап досліджує, як зібране сміття можна переробити на корисну сировину.
Крім сміття, у містах накопичуються величезні обсяги брудних стічних вод.
Годі уявити, але з того, що люди змивають в унітаз, теж можна видобувати цінні матеріали.
Нідерландські науковці розробили першу в світі установку для переробки стічних вод.
Із брудних стоків видобувають клейку речовину, так звану каумеру.
Її можна застосовувати, наприклад, у будівельній галузі, в авто- або велосипедній промисловості.
Для справжньої економіки замкненого циклу нам потрібна
переробка усіх стічних вод на корисні речовини.
Однак поки видобувається біогаз, який насправді майже не знаходить застосування,
а от наш клей у порівнянні з ним дуже цінний,
тож ми прагнемо виробляти для міста цінні будматеріали з його ж з стічних вод.
Традиційно клеї для промисловості виробляють з екологічно шкідливої нафти.
Новий тип клею є побічним продуктом спеціальної процедури
очистки стічної води бактеріями.
До 800 тонн клею на рік можна виготовляти на цьому обладнанні.
У цій майстерні до клею додають речовину на базі туалетного паперу.
Чого-чого, а цього продукту в місті вдосталь.
Додаються суміші з персикових кісточок, мигдальної або фісташкової шкаралупи.
Такі додатки дозволять будівельним матеріалам стати ще більш екологічними.
Дорожні знаки та фасади будинків на 80% із органічних складових - це вже реальність.
Проте потрібно провести ще багато додаткових досліджень і випробувань,
доки будматеріали зі стічних вод і туалетного паперу надійдуть у продаж.
Наш матеріал має кращі властивості, ніж тропічна тверда деревина,
і кращі, ніж алюміній, а це гігантський ринок.
В алюмінію дуже поганий показник СО2.
У нашого матеріалу безліч переваг. Подивимося, якою буде ціна.
Ми спробуємо у найближчі роки замінити алюміній
нашим матеріалом із клейковини.
Вторинна переробка органічного сміття та будівельних відходів у Амстердамі,
за оцінками, має фінансовий потенціал у понад 200 мільйонів євро.
Хоча нідерландська столиця давно вважається одним із найкращих міст світу
для велосипедистів, до економіки замкненого циклу місту ще далеко.
Принаймні, ціль уже поставлено: досягти цього до 2050 року.